هنا في Moss Landing California
، تقفز أكبر شركة طعام في العالم
على عربة اللحوم المزيفة التي سمعتها
عن البرجر المستحيل ، أما برجر ما وراء اللحوم ،
هذا هو إصدار نستله ،
البرغر الرائع
المصنوع أساسًا بنكهة بروتين البازلاء سهل
العصير  سهل ولكن الصفات المرئية
أكثر تحديًا ، فهو مزيج من
عصائر الفاكهة والخضروات التي
تخلت عن هذا النوع من اللون الوردي النابض بالحياة في عام
2017 ، استحوذت شركة نستله على أطعمة حلوة للأرض ، وهي
شركة متخصصة في الوجبات النباتية ،
كانت الأرض الحلوة قد بدأت للتو في
تطوير نبات نباتي نباتي
مفهوم برجر كان تعاونًا حقيقيًا
بين Sweet Earth وخبراتهم
ومعرفتهم بالطهي في
الفضاء النباتي جنبًا إلى جنب مع
علاقة Sweet Earth مع Nestle على نطاق واسع ،
وهو بالضبط ما
يميزها عن منافسي Silicon Valley
.
الطلب وما
وراء اللحوم استمر
في تكبد الملايين من الخسائر حتى أ  بعد
صراعات الاكتتاب العام الأولي الناجحة للغاية مثل تلك التي من
غير المرجح أن تصيب شركة تابعة لشركة نستله
، فقد حصلوا على الهندسة
والمشتريات وتصنيع
أنظمة التوزيع ، وهي
مزايا تنافسية تساعد في ضمان
إمدادات آمنة مستقرة من ناحية أخرى ،
مستحيل في الخارج.
حوالي عقد من الزمان وهم
في طليعة اتجاه اللحوم المزيفة
بينهم ، لديهم طلبات من
برجر كنج دانكن دوناتس وكنتاكي على
سبيل المثال لا الحصر ، سيكون البرجر الرائع
لديه الكثير من اللحاق بالركب اليوم
جميع اللحوم النباتية المقلدة.  يمثلون
حوالي 5٪ من الفئة على مدار السنوات
العشر المقبلة ، يمكنني أن أراهم يذهبون إلى 15٪
من إجمالي السوق ، وأعتقد أن هناك
مجالًا لعدد محدود من الشركات
للفوز في هذا المجال ، لكن نستله ليست
الشركة الغذائية الكبرى الوحيدة التي تحصل على  في
اللحوم المزيفة ، لدى كل من Kellogg Perdue و
Tyson منتجات مماثلة في الأعمال ، لذا
تتطلع شركة Nestle لإغراق المنطقة
بمطاعم خدمات الطعام والتجزئة
مما يعني
يمكن أن تظهر نسخة رائعة من اللحم البقري المفروم على بيتزا DiGiorno ،
لقد كانت نستله في Food & Food
Innovation لأنك تعرف ما يزيد عن مائة
وخمسين عامًا ، لذا على الرغم من أن
مساحة بديل اللحوم هذه
عصرية جدًا في الوقت الحالي
نفهمها وكيف نتفاعل  الاتجاهات والفوز
في السوق